gracias
cómo están todos bueno muchas gracias
porque mi universidad me invitó a dar
esta charla y también por ser la primera
así que espero no defraudarlo yo quiero
contarles una historia primero voy a
partir con una anécdota porque yo hace
10 años atrás bueno todo todo que me
nombraron en este currículum del mismo
científico hace 10 años atrás yo en una
periodista que me dedicaba a escribir
sobre espectáculo trabajaba en el diario
la tercera
escribiendo de televisión de música
hasta me tocaba escribir sobre farándula
hasta me tocó ir a cubrir todo este
problema que hubo con el chino ríos y la
journal azote la costa rica- imagínense
y yo siempre tenía esa idea de poder
hacer un periodismo diferente yo soy
hija de padre médico y madre tecnóloga
médica y siempre en mi casa se hablaba
de ciencia de tecnología de medicina y
siempre tuve esa intención de elegir un
periodismo que fuera más aporte a la
sociedad más allá de solamente como
decimos muchos periodistas que si
viviera para envolver pescado
entonces empecé con esa curiosidad de
decir cómo puedo llegar del espectáculo
a un periodismo mucho más interesante y
fue así que postulé finalmente un
magíster en comunicación científica
médica y medioambiental en españa que me
lo gané una beca en el año 2003 y por un
pololo no me pude ir llegué a quedarme
acá pero después dije no tengo que
hacerlo de esto de nuevo postura
nuevamente y el 2006 me fui a españa a
estudiar periodismo científico y fue así
como comencé esta gran historia de
divulgación científica después de haber
dado un vuelco en mi carrera con el fin
de emprender también en ciencias de
comunicación y tecnología cuando llegué
a chile yo quería hacer algo diferente
yo había trabajado también antes diez
años en radio comunicando sobre todo
para los jóvenes pero yo quería
comunicar ciencia cómo poder comunicar
ciencia cuando nadie me conocía en esa
área yo era una periodista de
espectáculos y llegué me acuerdo a radio
cooperativa con esta idea de hacer este
programa radial de ciencia y tecnología
golpee muchas puertas finalmente me
dieron esta oportunidad
pero tenía que conseguir auspiciadores
entonces como también convencer a
personas que puedan creer en mí de que
la ciencia la tecnología era importante
en la divulgación y fue así como toqué
más de 100 puertas muy pocas me lo
abrieron cerca de 4 personas creyeron en
mí y comencé esta aventura en la radio y
comencé con tengo ciencia con este
programa que comenzó en la radio en el
año 2009 con el cual inicié estaría
totalmente distinta a la que yo estaba
acostumbrada o sea yo venía de una área
como le decía sobre todo de cultura y
espectáculo y fue así como comencé
estuvimos tres años al aire en la radio
y pasó algo bien curioso yo estaba
contratada con la radio y ellos vieron
que yo empecé a traer auspiciadores y me
vieron como una amenaza y me echaron yo
dije bueno se me cerró una puerta pero
siempre dicen que se abre una ventana y
fue así como dije por qué no me
independizó y emprendo en ciencia y
comunicación y fue así como se me
ocurrió hacer una productora llamada
neurona group porque queríamos generar
sinapsis por eso el nombre de neurona
y fue así como comenzó también esta
nueva historia de emprender en ciencia
tecnología y comunicación y a pesar de
esta adversidad que me habían echado de
la radio dije no yo tengo que seguir con
mi programa igual y seguí haciéndolo de
forma externa trayendo auspiciadores
tocando puertas convenciendo a la gente
que comunicar la ciencia era importante
que teníamos que compartir el
conocimiento porque sin difusión no
existes y sobre todo los científicos
tenían que entender está alianza entre
el periodista y el científico de sacar
ese conocimiento del laboratorio sacarlo
al público a la audiencia a través de un
diario de un programa de radio un
programa de televisión y para que toda
la gente sobre todo los chilenos
supieran la gran ciencia y tecnología
que se desarrolla en nuestro país y de
alguna forma yo dije yo tengo que hacer
la herramienta entre el conocimiento
científico y la audiencia y fue así como
seguí con mi programa de radio a pesar
de que me habían echado seguí haciéndolo
de forma externa y
canal 36 me dice porque no pasamos este
formato de radio a la televisión y era
súper difícil o sea yo había hecho tele
antes pero haber pasado de radio
televisión de radio palabras a imágenes
como lo hago dije bueno porque no si
total de forma visual la gente gusta
mucho más de la ciencia que solamente de
la radio de mostrarles algo bueno y todo
ese desafío lo hice y comencé el año
2012 a hacer el programa fue difícil al
principio pero fue también fascinante
comenzamos con un programa corto de 30
minutos magazinesco hasta que en un
minuto yo dije cómo puedo llegar de
mayor forma a la gente con la ciencia no
solamente mostrando los laboratorios en
las universidades de los institutos sino
que hacerlos viajar conocer nuestros
laboratorios naturales conocer la
maravilla que hay en el norte en el sur
en el centro y dije por qué no hacemos
un giro hacia el turismo científico y en
chile el turismo científico estaba muy
poco explotado de hecho muy poca gente
sabe lo que es el turismo científico
y el turismo científico te invita a dos
experiencias una que es conocer las
historias ocultas que hay detrás de los
maravillosos paisajes que tiene chile y
aprender sobre las formaciones
geológicas de millones de años las
también cuáles son las etnias que
habitaron estos paisajes hace miles de
años atrás cuál es la flora y fauna que
pintan nuestros paisajes y cuáles son
los hallazgos científicos que han hecho
científicas y científicos en terreno y
fue así como hice este giro y fue un
boom jay me di cuenta bueno si mezclamos
otros formatos como en el turismo como
el viaje con la ciencia podemos llegar a
mucha más personas y eso también es una
invitación a como los científicos pueden
aprovechar sus conocimientos sus
proyectos y de alguna forma pintarlo o
buscar una idea diferente a cómo llegar
al público y yo me di cuenta que con
esta transformación de solamente pasar
del laboratorio físico a el laboratorio
natural podía llegar a muchas más
personas y así fue como lo logramos
y empecé a descubrir que chile tenía
oculto una cantidad de secretos
maravillosos y que muy pocos conocemos y
me di cuenta de que tenemos un
patrimonio inigualable natural histórico
y cultural que lamentablemente ni
siquiera nos interesa a veces saber
siempre viajamos y conocemos los
paisajes lindos a quien linda esta
postal que linda este lago que es lindo
de este parque nacional pero sabemos que
en lo que pasó ahí hace miles de años
sabemos lo que pasó ahí hace millones de
años sabemos que lo que está haciendo la
ciencia en ese lugar para ponerlo en
valor para divulgarlo para las futuras
generaciones para sentirnos más propios
de nuestras raíces yo creo que no fue
ahí donde ellos sentí que tenía esta
misión de poder generar mayor
conocimiento y viajar por todo chile
hacia este este momento que yo quería
mostrarle a cada uno de lo que yo estaba
viviendo a través del programa de
televisión bueno y ahora seguimos por el
programa televisión tecnociencia en ruta
llevamos ya cinco años entre cc el
programa también ha pasado a señales
internación
yo dije cómo puede llegar a más personas
no solamente con un programa de
televisión como puede ser una
multiplataforma seguir emprendiendo o
hacer spin-off de un producto y generar
nuevos productos de conocimiento y fue
así como dije porque no un libro de
turismo científico y recopilar toda la
documentación que había visto en mis
programas de tele grabando durante más
de 5 años a través de todo chile y
también de sudamérica y plasmarlo
también en un libro y fue así como dije
bueno hacer un libro una aplicación
porque también hay que pensar como la
gente se informa se informa a través de
un libro se informa a través de una
aplicación para celulares a través de
una página web y fue así como finalmente
cree está multiplataforma de turismo
científico única en chile porque no
existe otra así donde la gente pudiese
conocer las rutas de arica a punta
arenas
y si ustedes se dan cuenta tenemos una
cantidad de información tiene un país
arqueológico o sea tenemos una historia
de más de 10 mil años de conocimiento de
etnias que llegaron acá desde monteverde
que está cerca de puerto montt o sea
está datada en más de 12 mil años de
antigüedad
tenemos un cielo que es el más limpio
del mundo chile
se ha convertido en la capital de la
astronomía de acá los próximos años con
la creación del telescopio gigante de
magallanes de acá al 2021 en cerro las
campanas en la región de coquimbo
también con el lte en cerro armazones en
la región de antofagasta quién sabe si
el 10 de chile se descubre vida
extraterrestre no los enanitos verdes
como muchos se imaginan que vamos a
encontrar sino que vida microscópica se
imaginan que eso pasará desde los cielos
de chile silo es un país de dinosaurio
donde acá habitaron hace 150 millones de
años diferentes especies de dinosaurios
de hecho después vamos a tener acá a el
geólogo donde su hijo diego suárez fue
el que descubrió el chile saurio
entonces sí no
nos cuenta de eso podemos valorar mucho
más nuestro país y fue así como yo quise
seguir dando a conocer todo este
conocimiento con más plataforma quizá
ahora hicimos una exposición fotográfica
donde quisimos mostrar todas las fotos
que hemos recopilado durante las
grabaciones con la primera exposición
fotográfica de turismo científico en
chile- y contar esas historias ocultas
redescubrir chila con otros ojos darnos
cuenta de la riqueza que tenemos y
viajar con más consciencia a través de
la ciencia y así es como yo he querido
ir siguiendo con esta idea de querer
posicionar este turismo científico de
que chile se convierta en la potencia
mundial de turismo científico a quizá en
los próximos años que chile sea el punto
más importante de astro turismo a nivel
mundial y creo que eso se está logrando
con la estrategia que se está haciendo
en el gobierno pero creo que también
nosotros podemos hacer algo creo que
ustedes tienen mucho conocimiento y
donde ustedes pueden sacar este
conocimiento del laboratorio de los
papers conocerlo para que todas las
personas también puedan maravillarse con
la ciencia que
en nuestro país y uno que acá no
solamente en un país que tiene que
exportar cobre salmón vino sino que
también exportar conocimiento y si
nosotros nos apoderamos también de eso
de poder también generar estas ideas de
generar estos proyectos de divulgación
creo que las personas van a saber mucho
más de la riqueza que tiene nuestro país
y así como yo he querido seguir
trabajando ahora estoy este es el libro
y quiero seguir ahora haciendo 40 rutas
más de turismo científico por chile en
una segunda parte después de hacer un
tercer libro con 30 rutas más la idea
ahora es seguir viajando por chile para
poder mostrar estas maravillas mostrar
desde el ámbito geológico y
vulcanológico paleontológico ecológico
arqueológico y también astronómico todo
esto que tiene nuestro país y creo que
muy pocos sabemos esta riqueza que
tenemos yo los invito yo lo que de
alguna forma yo quería compartir con
ustedes a emprender a emprender en
ciencia a emprender en comunicación a
emprender desde la pasión muchas veces
nos da miedo porque para emprender
hay que tener tolerancia a la
frustración hay que ser perseverante hay
que tener un buen equipo de trabajo hay
que trabajar más de tres veces o el
doble o el triple o cuatro veces más de
lo que uno trabaja cuando está
contratado pero cumplir sus propios
sueños y no cumplir los de otros trae
una gratificación tan grande porque
finalmente uno crea hijos hijos que no
solamente vienen del útero sino que
vienen del corazón vienen de la cabeza y
eso no tiene ningún precio yo creo que
tenemos una deuda enorme creo que
tenemos una pasión enorme y creo que esa
conjugación de la pasión con esta deuda
que tenemos podemos llegar a mostrar a
chile como ningún otro país en el mundo
así que los invito a eso yo quise
compartir hoy mi experiencia como
comunicadora como emprendedora como
periodista que también dio un giro en su
carrera que dio un giro en su vida y que
también creyó que cambiar el camino
desde el espectáculo que no quiero
desmerecer a todos mis colegas que hacen
espectáculos pero meterme en el mundo de
la acción
creo que fue la mejor decisión que he
hecho en mi vida y si no tengo una
formación científica de base creo que
gracias a todos los científicos que
están acá hay científicas y lo que no
están acá me han ayudado nutrirme de ese
conocimiento y poder ser una herramienta
para transferir esta información y esta
pasión también a la audiencia muchas
gracias